John Cena well I'm thrilled that I don't
think this is the first time here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you John I'm
fantastic thank you for the introduction
oh yeah I'm thrilled to be chatting with
you I'm a big fan John thanks man I'll
try not to ruin it no no your comic
timing is I mean fantastic you're you're
a laugh out loud you stole train wreck
as far as I'm concerned
John you don't watch another movie
well let me ask were you on the set at
all with LeBron did that did those
moments ever no we we never crossed
paths and I would liked it because he
obviously is really proactive in
extending himself beyond sport and that
was kind of the beginning of my
expansion beyond sport as well so I just
love to pick his brain a little bit see
what he's doing and and how he's going
about doing that business and he's he's
done very well in that regard I would I
would I would agree with that so that
was essentially train wreck was your
first I guess big departure from from
the wrestling scene what you're saying
yeah so I literally did a lot of
unsuccessful movies in between like 2004
2009 and I really the reason was it I
blame myself certainly I my heart wasn't
in it I was really enamored with the WWE
and still am I'm super obsessed with its
audience and its programming and its
Superstars and just the the medium in
general I think it's a wonderful form of
entertainment for everyone across the
world that's why the company travels so
globally so often but I you know as a
young man I didn't have the patience for
the moviemaking industry and right
around the time of trainwreck I was kind
of reinvigorated with doing something
fun that was always branded as hey you
should only do these type of roles so I
just kind of went along with what I was
told and then trainwreck the beginning
of me choosing you know being fortunate
enough to choose the thing doesn't want
to do and since all the choices have
been my own which means they're you know
I'm passionate about it I think it shows
much more in the work and and you know
my kids
the voice of Ferdinand too as well I
mean yeah no you're you're most welcome
what was it like hosting the ESPYs for
you John I mean who did you get to meet
what was your favorite moment of that I
was uh that was me sweating through
about three tuxes and that was that was
never been in my entire life period
point-blank nervous is what you said oh
yeah that is it that is it what was
ESPYs it's because you know after the
show along with there is making you know
making light about a year in sports I
think the ESPYs thumbs up the Jimmy B
philosophy of like think laugh and cry
in one episode of ride today and a lot
of that comedy leans on the host and man
to be around athletes and be like a
sports entertainer which is not a
genuine whoever runs the fastest will
win you know whoever hits the ball
farthest will win we were more like
floor gymnastics we kind of rely on the
appeal of the people watching us so it
really was a tough room trying to throw
some zingers that you know real athletes
and everyone is there knowing that
they're gonna get hit or knowing that
they're gonna be shot in the crowd so
like no one wants to laugh but it I had
a great writing team and a great
creative force helping helping me plan a
monologue that I thought would would
take the edge off of everybody and I
don't wonder if a wonderful time but
I've never been as nervous for anything
John Cena here on the Rich Eisen show
bumblebee in theaters near you has been
out since December 21st we'll get to
that in a second is it safe to draw a
line from where you're from from where
you hail that you're a red sock Patriots
Celtic fan is that safest solution that
would be the assumption I've been around
the world so much I've pretty much been
living out of a suitcase for the past
two decades so I just I root for the
team that wins I like the bit okay okay
but but growing up it was oh yeah
growing up in New England certainly
gravitated towards the local sports
teams I think there
the Red Sox and Celtics were uh wouldn't
forefront and the Patriots and Bruins
were kind of in the backdrop okay
now your Center by Football trade from
back in the day is that a fact
they put me on the offensive line and I
kind of found a home they just told me
like hey go in this line someone will be
there hit down okay I can do that ok
definitely want to make sure that we
talk about your film a prequel to the
Transformers film bumblebee what does
this experience been like for you John
ah forever the salesman you are rich
thank you very non now no the experience
the experience was awesome
like I said I'm kind of choosing the
direction I'm in a pretty fortunate
position where I can kind of choose what
I am interested in and I think when
you're really interested in something
you know that you you know you put your
heart and soul into it and this was um
this was something that really jumped
off the page of me I think people who
have seen it agreeing that it's a
wonderful shot in the arm for the
franchise it's not what they'd expected
it really is a movie that has a very
powerful on all fronts and and it is a
fun ride like all the Transformers
movies before were so it's just it's a
it's really good to be part of something
that is critically acclaimed and
acclaimed by the audience as well
you know you put so much into making
these movies and then sometimes the
critics hate it and then the sometimes
the critics Katie and the audience hate
it and this is one of those lucky
circumstances were critics of loved it
and audience loved it to some I'm very
grateful yeah it's it's it's wonderful
if it only had a little bit more
production value in a bigger budget John
you know what I'm saying
yeah right more effects on it yeah so we
had to we had to turn back to technology
a little bit right uh maybe the next one
will evolved into the future and that
way we'll spend tons more money hey
before I let you go John
you know I know your your arrows may not
have passed too much but Mean Gene
passed away this week I'm wondering if
you have any great memories about him
passing away at the age of 76 Jean is an
absolute legend
I preached at the WWE Superstars never
take yourself too seriously and Jean was
an absolute not only a pro but he got
exactly what we did and that's that's
Mean Gene from a professional I think
there's
and they broke the mold on him you know
when they made genies truly one of a
kind he's from a professional standpoint
he's an absolute legend from a personal
standpoint he was a close friend and we
shared a lot of time together he used to
golf in a club down in Sarasota which
was a just an awesome situation than if
anyone ever stumbles across that to be
named nameless Club right now I want to
protect the innocence yes and finds
himself playing 18 holes just ask for an
Overland he had his own drink at the bar
I may have spent many a night with gene
and that's one Clubhouse drinking oklets
all night and telling stories it was it
not honestly he really was uh just he
loved what he did and he loved life and
yet he just had a you know he loved to
play golf but he loved to hang out like
that was his thing he just wanted to be
around people and I remember so many so
many fun nights of gene and so many fond
stories but as a as a professional I
think you know the work we do kind of
defines who we are and there was there
won't be one like Gene Okerlund he was
awesome well what was in that what was
in that concoction can you tell you know
if you if you ever asked for it you'll
find out I almost want us that what the
hell so go for it you know you don't
like it drink vodka and he was a vodka
cranberry man so commended 16-ounce foam
solo cup filled to the brim with ice
also filled to the brim with vodka of
your choice I'm the first guy thank you
for the sky campaign okay and they wish
they'd whisper the word cranberry over
and put the lid on it and happy
whisper the word oh yeah it literally is
the most clear pinkish hue a vodka
cranberry I've ever seen in my entire
life and to play a to play a team with
Gino and have a couple vocalists it was
just a wonderful relaxing day where you
could just you know escape the daily
grind and man--he I was lucky enough to
share a bunch of those moments with him
and I'm grateful for everyone yeah and
he was just I mean he was such a face of
face front person in the history of the
sport and obviously the entertainment
platform it was just sad to see it was
just too sad to hear about it you know
yeah it certainly I'm uh I'm like
everybody kind of mourn the loss and I
you know he lived a wonderful life and I
choose - I choose to remember the good
times I had with them and and the great
the great work he's done so we lost a
legend and there'll never be another but
I'm very grateful Fresno - for sure hey
Jon congrats on bumblebee and all of
your success I'd love to have you in
studio the next time so we could just
kick back and have a longer chat rich we
will definitely make that happen I know
you've been trying diligently and I
thank you I'm sorry we could do it over
the phone I promise any good on that
I'll come to the studio we'll talk about
I'm a patient man John Cena I'm a
patient happy new year - thank you you
bet that's John Cena go check out
bumblebee in theaters near you the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience